hey Traders it's Mike from orphos here
and I wanted to quickly talk about the
email that I've been sending out the
last couple days about the bundle from
Ninja caters called the ultimate Pro
pattern bundle now if you're like me
right and you know me you know I'm
always looking for tools or resources
that can help improve my trading in the
sense of finding more trades and I think
this bundle could be a big help for a
lot of you too not just uh you know
basically trading order flow because
when you wrap order flow around uh price
action or technical analysis or
technical patterns you know it just
gives you more confirmation in that
sense and
you know when I was talking to the guys
at ninja caters yeah I I have
conversations with them um you know
several times a month about you know
tools that I'd like to see or tools I
think could help us
um you know those of you in my sort of
trading tribe
um I say hey give us a special deal and
you know I think normally they sell this
whole pattern
parole bundle for about 9.97 on their
website but I got them to keep us an
offer at 397 for the pure pattern Trader
the Elliott wave Pro and the harmonic
pattern Pro now the ones that I focus on
is the pure pattern Trader and the
Elliott wave Pro but if you were to
scroll down to page this is copy of the
email by the way if you were to scroll
down you're going to see everything that
you get you get a lot of stuff honestly
um I mean just for the pure pattern
Trader Pro really that's all that I was
interested in and they're like well you
know what we'll make it a little bit
sweeter for you we'll throw in the
harmonic Pro bundle as well as the
Elliott wave package also sure I'll be
happy to tell my guys about this because
I think it's you know for that price
397. it's a fantastic price but um it's
normally 9.97 on their website but on
a chart right it's hard to you know
sometimes we're caught up in the in the
excitement of trading and trying to see
if something is developing we may miss
it right so this is right this is the
pure pattern Trader you can see it over
here on the left hand side right now I
just have the
um cup and handle formation turned on
because this was one that actually drew
me to that to to reach out to the guys
at ninja caters about this package
because
um you know I've been doing a lot of
analysis with cup and cup and handheld
patterns you know trying to draw them
myself and I know that they have this
tool which makes it a lot easier now if
you're not familiar with what the cup
and handle was is rather it was first
identified by
um Bill or William O'Neill rather
founder of that newspaper Investors
Business Daily I don't know if people
still read newspapers but um he wrote
about it in his book how to make money
in stocks it's a great book for trading
um you know on technical analysis and
basically what the cup shows is
consolidation after a trend right so
you're going to need a trend and the
handle is sort of the final shakeouts
ShakeOut of the Traders before the trend
resumes
okay so it's in my opinion it's quite a
strong uh powerful signal that you know
is going to basically help you as a
Trader find better trades now when I say
find better trades if you're using it
you could use it by itself but you know
me right I like order flow I use order
flow and when I see a pattern it will
just really quick you know this software
will run on a footprint chart so you
know you could you know what I do
honestly is I I keep a bar chart like
this open on a separate screen I just
have it scrunched up because I've got a
bunch of little screens you know running
sort of different
tools uh looking for basically for
um
you know any sort of patterns or support
reasons you know other things as well
and
you know then I'll sort of take it down
and I'll be looking at a footprint chart
done after that okay now if I see
something developing you know if I see a
pattern developing I'll look at the
order flow and I'll see you know do I
still have bullish order flow coming in
right because if I'm going to be looking
for this Market to keep moving what I
want to see is we're coming out of here
out of the handle part you know I want
to see Prominent Point of control I want
to see point of control at the bottom of
the bar I want to see
um you know some signs of absorption
coming in here as the market is getting
ready to move up all right
let's see if there's any other patterns
you know there's another pattern here
okay now the high a day is right here
1948-10 I've got a bullish signal here
it'll actually software you know it's
quite flexible you can um adjust you
know there's different uh settings you
know sort of your ratios of how you want
the handles to be relative to the cop
Etc
um you know the different colors you can
change around
um this volume part is this little thing
on top right you could have it as I have
a mountain you could have it as a
histogram you could have none I just
prefer to keep it as Mountain but things
like uh
you know is it here so
the projections
right sort of you know the invalidation
whether you know once it gets down to
this level basically the whole trade
idea is invalidated the projection
um up here
theoretic you know where the market
should go at a minimum
right so you know it sort of gives you
that
these levels
so well you know right because when it
kicks off the validation right the
market could still be below
of where the handle is sort of forming
it's hard to say I'll show you on a
chart but once it starts getting past
here right then I know here I got two
bullish boundar point of controls I've
got point of control on the bottom I got
three bullish ratios right so yeah I'm
looking for this to keep moving and you
know if I'm just looking at a chart I
may not
really take advantage of this trade or
even notice it developing but if I have
you know on my other screen you know a
small uh bar chart with this running on
it or you know even if I just have this
software running on the chart that I'm
looking at
um you know it's just going to highlight
things to me right which is what you
know as a Trader you want to see
you know here is a bearish cup and
handle formation
all right there's your cup there's your
handle if it gets up here trades
invalidated I'm looking for a Target
down here
right here's another one another bearish
one it gets up here trades invalidated
right and done where the target
production projection is down here
okay finally it hits that so you know
you can see how
useful the software is Right another way
that I've been exploring using it all
right is again let me just
show you is the um Elliott wave
okay because you know honestly back in
the
when I first started back in the day I
will say back in the day but um when uh
when when I was basically getting
started in in trading you know I I
didn't learn Elliott wave rather I sort
of learned sort of a mod modified
Elliott wave I would just look at
um wave count starting from zero right
and
I sort of I obviously over the years
I've moved away from it right and you
know what I've found is
you know when I start counting zero one
okay then I'll be looking for two to
come up here so we got to break this
High okay then count restarts here zero
one all I'm doing is I'm waiting for
this one to break out here
right right here
basically or the high here if this if we
can break out of this one because I know
we're going to go zero one two and three
is going to be up here right then look
I'll be pulled back
four right your previous
uh resistance now is your support
obviously and you're going to be looking
for it to go up but I'm always looking
at these counts of you know zero one
zero one anytime we can start it just
gives me a more automated way
um to do it
and I mean that's all I mean I don't get
it really too fancy
um you know I say oh it's a 2A 2B 3A 3.1
3.2 a nah for me I just keep it simple
right I believe trading should be kept
simple
look for the start look for you know
where it's going to start out at zero go
to one zero go to one break to two pull
back to two go up
simple trades like that then but that's
just me you know I prefer to keep things
simple but again you know it's a great
package if let me get back to the
website here if you go into the Ninja
if you have an account at ninja caters
right and you get this package you can
see it in here under Pro Series and
installation is very easy it's a little
bit uh you know all you gotta do is you
got to go in here to set up and download
you can download this what you do is you
just download the software
all right download here ninja Trader 8
and then you just uh there's a whole
setup thing you don't even need to start
ninjatrader uh to install it it's one of
those ones that will install outside of
ninja Trader and they have a guide a
user guide here
um or is it here
I wish I have it open here but it's it's
a nice you know 64 pages and it explains
you know how to use it how to set it up
because it it let's say it's complicated
but there's you know different settings
and you know you always want to know
what the settings are
okay and how to adjust it and and what
sort of adjustments that if you make how
it's going to change
um how it looks on the chart and they've
even got in here some little bonuses
um
like this one is pure pattern Trader
Market profiling
um it's by Kyle
if you're familiar with Kyle Kinney but
it talks about you know how you can use
the patterns together with other methods
of training and they've even got some
alive on demand uh trading you know they
got one two three recordings with
Richard krugel
um
you know showing you guys in real time
well they were recorded in real time
some trading sessions using the pure
pattern Trader so again you know
it's you know that that's the reason
that you're getting this email from me
about the pure
uh so the ultimate Pro pattern bundle
um I just wanted to show you like how I
use it and you know hopefully you know
you can use it uh that way as well right
or adapt it to your own style of trading
because you know at the end of the day
we just want to have tools that's going
to help us identify
um
you know more potential trading
opportunities right it's the market is
is very robust I mean you know again you
know it doesn't matter what Market
you're trading whether it's you know
this is gold right if you know I want to
look at say what is this uh Euro
currency right I'd be looking for the
same things potentially
right sort of the same setups right
anywhere there's you know a zero goes to
one breakout of the one
um
you know zero one break out of this one
here right looking for that move up or
you know maybe you're looking at the
patterns
right there's just so much you can do
with it and
it's you know
it'll be in a folder under your
indicators under ninja caters
and you just click on it to add right
now the first time you add pure pattern
Trader I think it's got
pretty much everything turned on and to
go through there to turn them off you
know here you can see
you know that's your triangle there
here's your double bottom here
what that is is it aligns with different
colors
um
you know but you can just see right
double bottom here is the head and
shoulders here right there's your
projection
um this was obviously fed speak there
but again you know even in the night
session right let's see little trades
coming through here
so it's pretty nifty tool you know I
think and you know anything that's going
to help you potentially identify
any trading opportunities is something
that you should look into
so thanks for watching this video and
you know hopefully you guys get this and
it gives you a few more extra trades a
month that can put you uh you know on
the right side of the win column so all
right everyone bye-bye